hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel on how to
survive in the online jungle
modern technologies open up new
sometimes incredible opportunities for
us but we have to pay with it with new
threats to our security
[Music]
today i'm going to talk about exactly
this using the example of the mysterious
event
that took place at gatwick airport
the christmas holidays of 2018 have been
remembered throughout britain
due to the unprecedented events that
took place at gatwick airport now this
is the second
largest airport in the country and it
was completely paralyzed by
unknown criminals second busiest airport
have been suspended
was it drone or drones more than one
thousand flights were
cancelled or delayed and this happened
over the 33 hour period
140 000 passengers were forced to change
their plans
altogether and the reason for this well
a pair of unmanned aerial vehicles
this all started on the evening of
december 19th when the security officer
on guard had just finished his shift
and he was waiting for the bus home
until around 9 pm
he noticed a pair of drones one of these
drones was circling over the service car
park and the other one was flying along
the fence of the airfield
so naturally he called a supervisor and
he reported the dangerous situation
only a few minutes later both gatwick
runways were closed
due to the threat of an aircraft
colliding with an unidentified aerial
vehicle
surely you've heard more than once that
birds pose a serious threat
to low-flying aircraft
unmanned aerial vehicles pose no less of
a threat to aircraft
and in the summer 2018 a group of
researchers from the university of
dayton simulated the collision of the
dji phantom 4 quadrocopter
with a light aircraft and at a speed of
383 kilometers an hour
the drone tore the wings placing
completely and punched this huge hole
through it the drone did not shatter
apart
it completely penetrated and it was
buried inside the wing
you see a hole in the leading edge here
the main spar is dented
in addition to this remote controlled
aircrafts can be used as weapons by
terrorists
for example five months before the
events took place at gatwick
drones are actually used in an attempt
on the life of the president of
venezuela
[Music]
but which drones are being used by
criminals well
when i say the word drone you probably
imagine a small quadrocopter that you
can buy at any major electronics store
right
according to eyewitnesses on the ground
at gatwick drones of a completely
different class
were appearing in the skies say hello to
the dji matrice 600 pro
this is an industrial drone it's often
used on the sets of tv series and
commercials but
modifications can be implemented for
patrolling large geographical spaces
such as warehouse complexes and
pipelines
but this kind of drone is also much
heavier it weighs more than 10 kilograms
it's already heavier than a bowling ball
but it can also lift five kilograms of
payload into the air
and spend more than 40 minutes in the
sky with it
now the prices are also pretty
impressive professional drones have
similar prices to used cars
for example this model costs just under
5 000 pounds
so two of these drones were spotted over
gatwick at once therefore the security
service had every reason to believe that
they were not faced
with some childish pranks something
serious was effort that could actually
threaten people's lives
[Music]
in the three hours after the first
report about the drones 58 flights had
to be cancelled or delayed
and from 9 to 11 pm the drones were
noticed by several more
airport security officers but then
suddenly the drones disappeared
without a trace therefore at midnight
the airport management decided to open
the runways
and just a few minutes later after that
the drones reappeared
over the skies of gatwick over the next
30 hours that story would repeat itself
nine times the drones would disappear as
soon as the airport was closed
and then they'd return when they noticed
the airplanes taking off or landing
later representatives of gatwick's
security service would state that the
attackers had an informant among the
airport's employees
but they weren't actually able to prove
anything here get out i need to go to my
mind palace
but i think everything is so much
simpler it was enough for the criminals
to download the flight radar 24 app now
this application shows the movement of
planes over any given place
on the map in real time with its help it
would be easy to monitor the state of
affairs at the airport and you wouldn't
have to bribe
employees or listen into the
conversations that were going on on the
radio
all night long the sussex police and
airport security were combing through
the neighborhood trying to find traces
of criminals or at least to scare them
away
in the morning a helicopter and several
police drones would actually join the
search but
none of these efforts would bring any
results the only thing that the police
were able to establish
was a deliberate act to disrupt the
airport
the situation was also complicated by
the fact that the police were forced to
fight with
well an almost invisible enemy
the drones that attacked gatwick were
too small and flew too low to be
detected by the airport's radars
therefore the only reliable source of
information here remains to be people
police officers security and ground
services
and the trouble is this airport occupies
1 670 acres
it's more difficult to find drones on
this huge territory than
well a needle in a haystack but
nevertheless
over 33 hours from the first appearance
drone flights were observed by people
12 times and in six of those cases
witnesses claimed that they saw a pair
of drones at the same time
later the case materials would actually
record the testimonies of 109 witnesses
who claim to have seen the drones
the attack on the airport ended as
unexpectedly as it began
early in the morning of december the
21st the airport was opened for the
tenth time
at 5 58 a plane from the east midlands
successfully landed over gatwick
and contrary to fears the drones did not
return
the airport began to return to normal
life and the airlines began to calculate
their losses
according to expert estimates during
these 33 hours of terror the companies
cumulatively suffered
losses of 50 million pounds but these
were not the final losses associated
with the incident
the police investigation of the attack
cost around 790 000
pounds and ended with well new losses
in hot pursuit the police detained a
married couple paul gates
and elaine kirk the interrogation of the
suspects took 36 hours but
ended in zilch there was no evidence
against them whatsoever and the alibi
that they had was actually confirmed
but the names of paul and elaine were
unfortunately leaked to the press
which obviously added fuel to the fire
we are deeply
distressed as are our family and friends
and we are currently receiving medical
care in june 2020 sussex police agreed
to pay the couple 200 000 pounds in
damages and legal costs for their
unlawful arrests
the investigation didn't yield any other
results and a total of 96 names appeared
on the list of suspects but
charges were never pressed to not one of
them there was simply no evidence
in this case whatsoever therefore on
september 27th 2019 sussex police
officially dropped the investigation
stating
that it's impossible to continue this
investigation without any new
information
but doesn't this bother you i mean no
terrorist organization
group of hackers or ecoactivists has
made any demands
whatsoever or a submitted responsibility
for what happened to gatwick
no suspects no evidence there weren't
even any clear photos or videos
seems like it's time to call fox mulder
for help or to ask the question
were there any drones in the first place
now i was actually interested in the
story of eddie mitchell
he's a news photographer by profession
and an enthusiast for the use of drones
during the attack he spent almost a day
in gatwick and he was hoping to take
successful photos of the drones but
his expectations were not met when eddie
was actually about to leave the airport
and he was loading his things into the
car
the drone's warning light seemed to
flash over his head
so mitchell took a few shots and
anticipating success obviously but when
he opened the photos on his laptop
he realized that he mistook well the
drones for a helicopter
that was flying 10 miles away from the
shooting location
here's a quote if i'm making a mistake
and i fly drones two or three times a
week then god help us because others
will have no
[Music]
idea
it's funny actually talking about this i
remember the story of the appearance of
edison stars
in i think it was 1897 when the great
inventor
was experimenting with a range of radio
signals
and with the help of balloons he raised
long antennas into the sky
and obviously to simplify the
observation of such balls in the dark
edison fixed bright bulbs to them the
newspaper men who were following
every step of the scientist quickly made
a mountain out of a molehill
there are articles that edison was
working on lamps that could rise into
the sky to illuminate the whole country
they would have been so powerful the
light of the lamp would be
seen over the pacific ocean the articles
multiplied right and they were reprinted
from newspaper to newspaper and
new details required like chinese
whispers everyone saw
edison's lamps all over the night sky
americans were looking out for the
edison stars
and they found them right the lights
actually scared the locals they
prevented astronomers from
following the stars and they became
overgrown with rumors
they were seen as huge balls and as
small little lights people were looking
for the lights and they wanted to see
them
i think we may have experienced the same
effect at gatwick
you've got dozens of tired and anxious
people looking for drones in the night
sky
and bear in mind it's not that difficult
to make a mistake at the airport you've
got the likes of
helicopters and planes all flying at
high altitudes you've got beacons on
tall buildings police drones
and this is all catalyzed by the fear of
new technologies you've got articles
coming out
and news constantly about the new threat
of drones
now all of this in my opinion could help
people to see things that weren't
actually there
at least this version reliably explains
the absence of traces evidence photos
and
also explains the radar silence
anyway most of those that are interested
in the history of the incident at
gatwick are divided into two camps
the first defend the version of the
high-tech crime itself
the second they blame collective
hysteria and journalists who are greedy
for
catchy headlines right me personally i
think the truth lies somewhere in the
middle
and i can only say one thing we are
responsible for the technologies that we
create
any programs or services that make our
lives brighter and more comfortable
can easily turn against us but anyway
this is some sub i hope you subscribe
i'm bradley your guide in the predatory
world of the online jungle i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]